hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach today I will talk about
chickens and pigs like chickens and pigs
once I got did with a chow well here's
the story a pig and a chicken are
walking down the road the chicken says
hey pick I only think we should open a
restaurant
take replies hmm maybe what will we call
it the chicken response
how about ham and eggs the pig thinks
for mountain says no thanks I'd be
committed but you'd only be involved so
it's a story about how committed someone
is to the cause the ham requires the pig
sacrifice while the chickens eggs are
easy to produce traditionally the
development team were the pigs while
everyone else including product owners
scrum masters customers and other
stakeholders were chickens the idea was
that Peaks got the priority for talking
during team meetings sometimes chickens
were even expected to remain silent
unless invited to speak because they
weren't the ones who rather bacon on the
line can SH we were co-creators from
used to tell the story about chickens
and pigs and it was even part of the
scrum guide however can and as
co-creator Jeff Sutherland removed it
from the scrum guide in 2011 because it
got a little too derogatory in practice
developers might say something like the
stakeholder can't talk to us during
daily standup they're just a chicken
it's true we do want the development
team to be able to focus on their
meetings without getting derailed but
calling our leadership pea-brain Birds
is it going to win us any favors since
it hasn't been part of the scrum guide
in quite a while you may hear the term
less and less often that's perfectly
okay and it's still fine to use the
terminal organization just don't use it
as a chance to be it up in your
stakeholders if you really think about
it we've all got our bacon on the line
best of luck
aren't going